,
JUDGE.
>> I'M JUDGE JEANINE PIRRO IN
FOR LAURA INGRAHAM TONIGHT, AND
THIS IS THE INGRAM ANGLE FROM
NEW YORK CITY.
WE HAVE A BIG SHOW FOR EACH
NIGHT, LET'S GET INTO IT.
PRESIDENT BARTUS TOLD US THAT HE
WOULD
BRING COMP TO THE COUNTRY, BUT
SO FAR, HE'S ONLY BROUGHT MORE
LAWLESSNESS AND CHAOS.
RIGHT NOW, DEMOCRAT LEAD
SAFETIES ARE UNDER SIEGE BY
RAMPANT CRIME DUE TO THE LEFT'S
OPEN EMBRACE OF BLM'S RADICAL
AGENDA OF DEFENDING AND
DEMORALIZING THE POLICE.
NOW THAT IT'S CLEAR RUNAWAY
CRIME ISN'T AN ELECTION WINNING
PLATFORM, DEMOCRATS ARE ACTUALLY
ATTEMPTING TO PAINT THE G.O.P.
AS THE REAL COP HATERS.
>> THEY ARE THE ONES ACTUALLY
DEFUNDED THE POLICE BY
$1.9 TRILLION, THEY VOTED
AGAINST THE SUPPLEMENTAL FOR --
>> LET'S TALK ABOUT WHO DEFUNDED
THE POLICE, AND EMERGENCY RELIEF
PLAN FOR CITIES THAT WERE CASH
STRAPPED AND LAYING OFF POLICE
AND FIREFIGHTERS, IT WAS THE
REPUBLICANS THAT OBJECTIVE.
>> THIS RISING CRIME IS NOT THE
FAULT OF THE MOVEMENT, IT'S THE
FAULT OF THE POLICE.
>> Judge Jeanine: IF WE HAD A
REAL PRESS CORPS, THEY WOULD
LAMBASTE THEM CUTS FOR MAKING
LUDICROUS CLAIMS.
INSTEAD, THEY ARE TRYING TO
SHIELD JOE BIDEN FROM THE BLOW
BACK.
TO "THE WASHINGTON POST,"
SO-CALLED FACT-CHECKER RIGHTS
REPUBLICANS KEEP TRYING TO TAG
BIDEN WITH BEING PART OF THE
DICTAPHONE TO THE POLICE
MOVEMENT.
THAT
SIMPLY FALSE.
IT MIGHT AND WANTS TO BOOST
FEDERAL FUNDING TO ALLOW FOR THE
HIRING OF MORE POLICE OFFICERS.
HE SAID THAT DURING THE
CAMPAIGN, AND THEN FULFILLED
THAT PLEDGE IN HIS INITIAL
BUDGET PROPOSAL.
HE HAS BEEN ENTIRELY CONSISTENT.
BIDEN HAS BEEN SO REMARKABLY
CONSISTENT THAT THE LARGEST
POLICE UNIONS ENDORSED
DONALD TRUMP LAST ELECTION.
WHILE BIDEN MAY -- HIS ACTIONS
SPEAK LOUDER THAN WORDS.
HE APPOINTED TWO DEFUNDED THE
POLICE ACOLYTES TO TOP POSITIONS
IN THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT.
FIRST, KRISTEN CLARKE WHO WROTE
THIS JUST MONTHS BEFORE BEING
NOMINATED, QUOTE, DEFUND THE
POLICE, BUT BE STRATEGIC.
ONE OF THE BEST WAYS WE CAN
HONOR THE LEGACY OF GEORGE FLOYD
IS BY PUTTING IN PLACE REFORMS
THAT REDUCE THE FOOTPRINT OF
POLICE OFFICERS AND COMMUNITIES.
THAT'S ALMOST VERBATIM WHAT
BIDEN'S OTHER RADICAL DOJ
APPOINTEE TOLD CONGRESS LAST
SUMMER.
>> A NEW PARADIGM OF A LOOK
SAFETY.
NOT JUST CHANGING POLICING
PRACTICES AND CULTURE, BUT
ULTIMATELY SHRINKING THE
FOOTPRINT OF THE CRIMINAL LEGAL
SYSTEM, INCLUDING POLICE AND
BLACK AND BROWN PEOPLE'S LIVES.
>> Judge Jeanine: HERE'S
SOMETHING ELSE THE MEDIA WANTS
YOU TO MEMORY HOLDS, IT'S
DEMOCRAT CITIES THAT DEFUNDED
THEIR OWN POLICE DEPARTMENT.
>> PEOPLE SAY, YOU DEFUNDED THE
POLICE.
I SAID, HOW DO YOU THINK OUR
CURRENT SYSTEM IS WORKING?
>> THE REALITY IS, WE CAN'T RELY
ON THE POLICE TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
SAFETY, THAT'S A 1990s VERSION
OF PUBLIC POLICY.
>> YOU CUT --
>> WE ARE REIMAGINING PUBLIC
SAFETY TOGETHER WITH OUR POLICE
DEPARTMENT.
>> Judge Jeanine: IT'S AND ME
CITIES WHERE YOU HAVE SEEN THE
MOST BRAZEN CRIMINAL ACTS.
JUST YESTERDAY, PHILADELPHIA
POLICE WERE ACTUALLY FIRED UPON
WHILE TRYING TO RESCUE A
19-YEAR-OLD GUNSHOT VICTIM HAD
BEEN HIT IN HIS CHEST.
LAST SUMMER, PHILLY CUT
$33 MILLION FROM ITS PROPOSED
POLICE BUDGET, MURDERS ARE NOW
UP 36% FROM LAST YEAR.
AND THEN THERE'S THE SHOCKING
STORY FROM OAKLAND WHERE ARMED
ROBBERS, ARMED ROBBERS ATTEMPTED
TO HOLD UP A NEWSGROUP AS THEY
INTERVIEWED THE CITY'S CHIEF OF
VIOLENCE PREVENTION.
THIS CAME JUST HOURS AFTER
OAKLAND'S POLICE CHIEF RAILED
AGAINST CITY OFFICIALS FOR
SLASHING HIS BUDGET.
>> NOT HAVING RESOURCES MADE HER
CITY LESS SAFE.
SATURDAY NIGHT, A SCENE WHERE
YOUNG MEN LOST THEIR LIVES.
A LADY YELLED OUT, DO SOMETHING
ABOUT IT.
WITHOUT THE RESOURCES, IT MAKES
IT CHALLENGING TO MAKE OPEN
CITIES.
>> Judge Jeanine: OAKLAND'S
MURDER RATE IS UP 19.1%,
APPARENTLY THOSE ARE ACCEPTABLE
LOSSES FOR DEMOCRATS.
THEY ARE ONLY NOW BLAMING
REPUBLICANS FOR THEIR OWN
POLICIES BECAUSE IT SUITS THEIR
ELECTORAL NEEDS.
NEXT TIME THERE ARE MASS BLM
PROTESTS IN THE STREET, THEY
WILL BACKSTAB LAW ENFORCEMENT
WITHOUT A SECOND THOUGHT.
I DON'T BELIEVE ME?
LONG BEFORE BIDEN DECIDED HE
SUPPORTED POLICE OFFICERS, HE
WAS PANDERING TO THE BLM
RADICALS, PUTTING CITIES TO --
>> MILITARY AND BAITING, THEY
KNOW ANYBODY, THEY'RE SUPPOSED
TO BE PROTECTING THESE PEOPLE.
MY GENERIC POINT IS --
>> UNTIL WE CAN AGREE THAT WE
CAN REDIRECT SOME OF THE
FUNDING.
>> YES, ABSOLUTELY.
>> Judge Jeanine: NEX